so
i'm dave mccrory
i'm i work for a winter music group and
i'm going to moderate
moderate this panel around aws apis and
openstack and probably quite a few other
things i'm sure we'll end up
going into this as we get started
so next to me this is randy bias
ceo of cloud scaling
i've actually known randy for a while
he's a pretty nice guy although some
people might disagree with me on that
this is nadi shalom next to him he's
with giga's faces and now he's been
around for quite a while
and i've watched his gigaspaces has
grown and done all sorts of interesting
things and uh now
now does a lot of interesting things
with cloudify and this is alex friedland
who this is the first time i've met alex
is with uh mirantis he's the ceo of
hope i got all that right and didn't
screw anything up
all right fantastic
i'd also like to point out a tiny bit of
disclosure
while while i'm not directly affiliated
with openstack my wife is she's with
piston cloud another openstack
vendor as well
so
i think we should get started with maybe
talking about
more of
what is happening with uh with aws
and
the apis and kind of
the
connection
with the enterprise and kind of maybe
what we're seeing and in some cases not
seeing
um
so
i'm sure this will lead us where we need
to go
wants to go first i got handed the mic
so i guess it's me there you go
is this thing on i hope so
all right so um i just want to clarify a
couple quick things i mean part of the
reason we're doing this panel is because
i created a kerfuffle with uh a big blog
post and i did about um a big blog
posting i did about embracing um about
the openstack community embracing amazon
and somehow that's been misinterpreted
into
openstack embracing the aws apis and i
think the problem with that
misconception is that the aws apis or at
least the ec2 and s3 apis are already in
openstack so that's not that's never
been my position my position has been
that because the amazon's the largest
public cloud and has this huge ecosystem
that it's in the benefits of the
openstack community to see
amazon as a friend and as a partner in
building cloud computing and making the
pi bigger for everybody
and driving adoption
not to see them as an enemy and that
certain sub-components of the openstack
community and i'll just go out and name
names namely rackspace among some others
like to draw a picture of amazon being
you know evil right or the enemy or
vmware is the enemy and i just think
that that doesn't make sense it's
counterproductive and what we're all
trying to do is make openstack succeed
and that means there needs to be very
many there needs to be many flavors of
openstack that support a bunch of
different apis of which uh aws
compatibility is one
so i think that the the main point if i
want to kind of frame what the
discussion at least the way i interpret
it is that uh really we're talking about
the probability of openstack to other
clouds and i think that one thing that
came out pretty good from randy's
past
is kind of the raising of the red player
gay guys you might be going in a certain
direction and it's not necessarily the
direction that you're
you're actually want to go which is the
lack of probability of looking at amazon
in the competition
and the thing that i felt that is
requires more discussion is how do you
first of all what is political
portability with what which cloud is
that on the amazon and uh or is that
also google
azure all those type of things in that
case while we zoom into an api
discussion
where the actual portability aspect
might be a more broader aspect so that's
kind of
the point that i wanted to take in terms
of the discussions but ability is the
right thing but then let's define what
is probability and what's the right way
to deal with probability
he's going to say alex you have to have
an opinion after all of this yeah you
bet you have to have an opinion so
uh this is uh for those of you who might
have followed this this is uh
round three of the debate and uh
i think you know for this to be a debate
we have to have differences of opinion
otherwise it can be boring so
boris lost round one because he
basically said there is no
difference of opinion and everybody said
rent you one
so i have to have something so um i
think we're all agreeing that uh all
trying to make
openstack uh part of the cloud computing
ecosystem and a very very important part
for that matter and that means it's all
about the customers what does it take
for customers to be able to use whatever
the option they want in the most easy
way
and when amazon
becomes a dominant um
ecosystem it actually builds the market
and one of the reasons for openstack to
be there is because not everybody wants
to be on amazon so the you know the
speed of growth of openstack will be
very much tied to
amazon so we're going to love amazon but
then the question becomes for us as the
community
what is the priority you know when do we
actually worry about the apis and
compatibility and what are the things we
need to do today versus tomorrow to
make sure that openstack is actually a
you know a good competitive ecosystem so
that customers can really take advantage
of it because today
lots of people are talking about it but
how many people have truly taken
advantage of openstack is this question
so if we can solve that problem all as a
community i think you know our companies
are going to be successful and openstack
is going to be successful and cloud
computing will be successful i
i think i i have a question then if we
if we follow this path of amazon being
the dominant player and
we embrace uh amazon's apis
um
i think there are a couple of questions
at least that i would ask the first is
which apis as amazon continues to grow
their services and
creates new services which then of
course have new apis
and so in which layer do you
or where do you stop with the apis i
mean currently openstack supports the
equivalent of api compatibility for some
of amazon's apis not all of them
and
obviously amazon's free although they
would pay quite a penalty from the
community to change their apis and so as
you
as you do that you take on risk as do
you take on risk with any of these apis
that you
that you replicate so we have to be
careful about which apis and for what
purpose are you what purpose do you gain
by keeping compatibility so you have to
keep that in mind at least
that's what i had
on
so i i don't know that we need to pick
where we stop right i mean it's really
the community as a whole pick where we
stop i don't why should i draw a line i
mean you look at openstack heat which
came out of red hat it's a rewrite of
cloud formation it's got the cloud
foundation and the cloud watch apis in
it so
you know there's a whole bunch of aws
apis in the openstack ecosystem now
i don't see any reason to draw a line i
mean the community will fast follow us
at fast follows in terms of
the api stability the amazon apis in
openstack have been the most
stable set of apis at least for ec2
above and beyond openstack's native nova
apis the rackspace apis
they've been far more stable and part of
the reason is is that if you look at
amazon's history to date so far they
generally don't kill backwards
compatibility because they've got a
massive ecosystem so they can't really
do that easily and they're not going to
do that easily so this it's a little bit
of a red herring to go oh you know if we
follow the aws apis and amazon can just
change it willy-nilly and we're at their
beck and call it's like no that's not
really the situation they're not going
to change it willy-nilly let's talk
about things that are real because that
that's going to break their own
ecosystem yes they're going to add stuff
that is in there and they're going to
know about it in advance of openstack
and openstack would always be fast
following but on the other hand the
advantage is that we get to allow
customers who are on amazon today to get
off onto openstack very easily and i
think we all want that and we all want
to enable hybrid cloud um and so you
know how we're going to do that unless
we have great support for as many of the
aws apis as makes sense
yeah the problem that i have with even
with the question is that we immediately
jumped into the assumption that what
we're doing from compatibility is aws
api and then which api we choose and so
forth and so forth and
that line of thought assumes that
probability equals interoperability and
portability only to amazon
now if you're growing that discussion
and think about probability which i
think the point that
came out right in randy's post
what about google what about azure what
about why should we limit ourselves into
aws and in that case
why are we talking about aws api why we
now talk about something that will
actually work with all of them should we
do a bridge per api per cloud
and and that's kind of another question
that comes immediately after that rather
the option to
to deal with affordability is that only
applicability or apartment credibility
is
one option but again if you look at
different apis that each cloud provider
have
going with the path of api credibility
means that you need to have a breach of
api and you're going to do some chasing
of each of those vendors to maintain
compatibility so if you're only looking
at compatibility or affordability in
amazon then api becomes something more
sustainable but if you look at that even
more product context it's not
necessarily that's that's sustainable
and i'm not sure that we need to narrow
the probability only into amazon so i
think
the discussion should be first what is
portability and do we mean probability
only to amazon something broader
second what are the options for doing
probability and whether api
compatibility is the right options and
there are more than one option to deal
with probability and i'll begin with
probability for three so i think
the discussion should start there in my
in my point
so i just i want to ask you a question
nadi since you've been dealing with the
portability issue jumping in taking
dave's job don't shoot me
um
when
what i what i've posited before is that
it's about more than apis it's about the
architectural behavior and sort of the
semantics and the semantic behavior and
so what i mean what i mean by that is
like if i spin up a vm on cloud a and i
spin up a vm on cloud v and this one
takes me five minutes and this one takes
me an hour the problem is is that the
app layer or the portability layer the
abstraction layer doesn't make
allowances for an hour to spin up a vm
things break and so you know it's not
enough to copy api's you actually have
to copy architecture right that's why
doblick which runs on android is just a
complete clean rewrite of the jbm but it
behaves and acts in almost the same way
i mean what are you finding that
problems are with portability at a
non-api architectural level between
cloud yeah so that's a that's a very
good question but actually that
that implies why you can't put just a
layer of api for example of amazon
because people assume certain behavior
when you do that and if the cloud
happens to spawn at vm in
three minutes or less than three minutes
or ten minutes and you're still using
the amazon api then you might actually
get a completely different experience
which is the area now back to your
question i think that the the
probability aspect or the concept of
portability in general
and if you follow the history because
when i don't think that it's unique to
to openstack that question uh we always
use the parallel of linux to describe
what amazon is or what openstack is
doing and if we look at linux and how
linux dealt with that then there was an
attempt to do kind of api compatibility
everyone knows sequin
everyone use sequin here sure
have you used it in production as well
okay old man okay
and
does anyone heard about the lintos
okay so we got one to use so i'm saying
that the history shows that uh
yes there is a dominant player that it
was in the case of linux it was windows
but you don't necessarily need to have
the same api to actually not just win
the battle but also maintain portability
another example that is more recent is
android and ios and you mentioned that
right now uh when ios sorry when android
came out to the world ios was a dominant
player
they could have picked up the right
strategy or one strategy and actually
there wasn't too much too many player
like in the cloud to say let's embrace
the ios api and that would be the
strategy yet they did it and still you
maintain probability people do write
applications to both platforms and
they're being successful and android
have been actually very successful
taking that
strategy
so come back to your question i think
that if you look at probability it's
really
how do you deal with the scope of change
and the basic idea is not to create a
leak obstruction it's not to hide the
differences
but minimize the scope of the
and that's the core thing you know that
amazon behaves that way i'm not going to
hide that i'm not going to create an api
that tells you that now
google looks like amazon or
vmware looks like amazon because they're
not but i'm going to minimize the change
and we can have a discussion how you
minimize the change but that's kind of a
more philosophical discussion and
practical discussion around that
well i you know happened to be you know
very close to where nazi unfolds here
but
i think
we're putting a cart a little bit in
front of a horse today
because before we talk about
interoperability we need to make
you know the horse to work and today i
mean we have
probably you know the largest number of
live customer engagements and production
customer engagements of anybody in the
openstack ecosystem
more than 60
production implementations of openstack
for all kinds of customers and i must
say that
the driving force for this has never
been somebody trying to kind of leave
amazon and go to openstack that's not
why they do it they do it for
diversification reasons they do it for
internal politics they do it for
strategy reasons and right now that is
the driving force and so what we're
seeing the issue is today is the
internal engineering of how openstack is
built isn't quite ready for prime time
and you know for a small
setup maybe of 100 servers it kind of
works but try to put it on 500 servers
as you know a trunk it's actually a big
problem when you look at how it's
engineered you look at the problems you
have
at the schedule level and what happens
if you start you know spawning virtual
machines and suddenly
um you know the scheduler becoming a
bottleneck and many things of that
nature and the technical committee which
is not today dominated by benevolent
dictator doesn't have a very strong
opinion as to how this is done so i
think the priority that we want to take
as a community is to make openstack work
like a true cloud ecosystem and there
are different ways to make it work one
is what randy's company has done and
they're known to be very very strong
engineering guys and they've built the
version of openstack that is probably
engineered very very well and that's a
solution the other solution is how do
you make the trunk be engineered better
and ultimately for mass adoption the
latter is probably a more important uh
problem for us to solve as a community
because when we talk to a lot of
customers they're interested in
uh
innovation coming from open source not a
specific version of somebody else's
innovation and so if we can solve that
problem
and it's engineered right then the
problem of interability will be
interoperability will become a real
problem to be solved and it will be
solved at multiple levels one level is
we have people like right scale and
others who will create layers above and
will go deep inside the ecosystems and
create a solution there'll be other
they'll do it at the api level and what
i offer that you know ranking might want
to consider is take a project inside
openstack called amazon api as a project
and just basically write it and own it
and be the you know the go to guy where
everybody wants you know api level
compatibility and community will embrace
it right away but i don't know that for
our success as ecosystem this is the
number one priority that's that's where
i say
yeah that's great i don't think i ever
said it should be the number one
priority i just said we shouldn't
demonize amazon and it's been pretty
clear in the posting that's the case um
i just want to kind of rebut a couple of
things
i might have done a few openstack
production deployments um as you know
and um
working with mirantis on a few of those
and we are seeing people come off of aws
that's a very common use case i've got
about four startup customers right now
one of them is spending millions of
dollars a month on amazon web services
and they want to cost optimize that they
want to run it on openstack or at least
a fair bit and they want to run a hybrid
cloud
and one of the world's largest retailers
is about to go with us um and they've
got thousands and thousands of virtual
machines and one dot extra largest on
amazon that they want to pull back and
what's happened is that you probably
have all noticed that over the last 15
years software companies new startups
have changed dramatically they don't
actually buy their own hardware anymore
they all start on amazon and so what's
key about that is that people are still
growing their enterprise businesses
through acquisition so symantec six
billion dollars of revenue half of that
is sas
half of it is sas
you should qualify
many startups start on amazon but not
many you mean doing hardware or you're
writing say systems management for
software right
if you're pure software or you're
focused on sas then you go on it
absolutely and so and so there's a there
are great reasons to want to pull people
off amazon web services so i think it's
a little bit of a mischaracterization to
say that that use case doesn't exist
because i know that it does and i can
prove that it does
um and then the second is is that you
know i think we all want openstack to be
better right i mean the the point of
sort of making the engineering and trunk
better is great like i'd love to do that
right i mean there's stuff that we could
push back you know that people could
ding us for that we haven't um and i
think that's fine and you know over time
we'll push that stuff back but the
problem is is that the community
strength right now is also its weakness
it's about inclusivity and it's about
innovation and so there's so many people
trying to tug it in all kinds of
different directions i mean look at
everything that's in there all the
different network providers and storage
providers hypervisor support and bare
metal and linux containers and just you
go on and on and and on right it's hard
to like put good engineering into that
because i might make a design decision
for like lxc or bare metal that makes no
sense for hyper v and esx
right and there's nobody to break those
ties except for the ptl's
right so i like to look at openstack as
being like the linux kernel right do you
download the linux kernel and compile it
from source
maybe some of you do but
you know the majority of us don't right
i mean the majority of us go get a bank
distribution right downloading
openstack's not like downloading mysql
and turning on database it's like
downloading the linux kernel and then
you gotta compile the damn thing add a
user land put in an installer like
figure out how to support different
hardware i mean it is a huge huge thing
so i think it behooves the community to
actually embrace the product companies
like us that are trying to bring to
market a specific flavor of openstack
you know an aws google compute engine
flavor i mean hey that might not win but
there are some customers who may want
that somebody else may go do an hpc
openstack somebody else may go do some
other you know i was talking to the vce
guys they want to put openstack on the v
block
right i mean that wouldn't have been my
first choice of where to put openstack
but if somebody wants to put on feedback
power to them right but you know i just
think it's really hard at this point to
sort of say let's put all the great
engineering in trunk because a lot of
that is going to be contentious i don't
think it's clear but i can engineer for
a specific use case and i can make that
use case really great and that's where i
think that we we want differentiation in
the ecosystem
oh wait a minute
i do have one question if we if we go
down that path
doesn't that mean that trump takes
forever to evolve and eventually
if you have enough of these competing
interests
you you end up with something that
starts to lag further and further and
further behind doesn't there need to be
something that allows allows it to
to work in parallel so that many of
these needs can be met at the same time
and maybe that is
maybe that is some specific
deeper focus on solving specific
problems including by the way
different companies may be focusing on
api compatibility for different cloudy
services
i agree with your comments nadi that
we
it might be better if we
if we avoid
trying to do pure abstractions i know i
certainly tried to do that a long time
ago with hypervisors it never works
you can't abstract hyper-v kpm and
vmware to look the same it's impossible
you end up getting these nuanced
behaviors that become impossible to
replicate on the other
and if you hide it
everything that depends on it fails so i
agree with that but what you can do is
create
leaky abstractions that that let you do
enough things to get some jobs done and
the question is what are you trying to
get done are we focused on management
and automation tools like a right scaly
kind of thing where you're doing
deployments and things across these
where i need a deep amazon
ec2-ish compatibility or am i focused on
applications that actually run inside
and on top of these the vms and such
that that are really being built by
openstack right ultimately you want to
run applications on this damn thing
anyway if you're not running apps why'd
you pause the value
so so break the
answer into three parts one of them when
we talk about
what are the scenario that we're talking
about so usually it will be switch like
the customer that you probably mentioned
i'm paying too much to amazon and i'm
going to do a complete switch which
means that the probability is one of
f4 there is the hybrid cloud scenario in
which it's a continuous effort i always
want the two to work and the same goes
with dr
which i'm gonna switch only when
something fails in one cloud and
whatever is that so those are the would
say three difficult scenarios where
probability comes to mind uh obviously
the first one is kind of in my view in
our case because we do look at
the future as more of the hybrid cloud
so it's availability is going to be more
continuous kind of effort
then to your questions
do we
what are the options for maintaining
portability one option is to do api
compatibility and i mentioned one
problem that is that if we think about
only amazon that's one scope but if you
think about amazon azure and
google and vmware
then it becomes a completely different
scope uh just doing that for every club
and then the question is what what is
the second option is there a second
option for apr capability and still
maintain capability and yes the right
scale approach which is templating model
is also a valid approach and there is
advantage to that and there is
disadvantage to that there is no by the
way there is no solution that is you
know 100 percent
guarantee that portability will be a
zero effort
the difference that i think people have
with that approach and i heard uh randy
talking about that a little bit is that
yeah so so the the main concept about
that approach with the templating
approach which i think uh hit is
actually going in that is that
you're basically trying to minimize the
change and let's talk about minimizing
the change when we talk about
application the application code is not
really specific to amazon i'm writing to
my sql i'm writing to
simple dvd
oh rds
if you're writing a simple debut then
you're doing something wrong but most
applications will not read to amazon api
and i don't think that
most of the applications are really into
those proprietary services most of the
applications are related to middleware
that runs in this would run pretty much
the same on amazon i would run on an
operating system most of the things that
when we talk about affordability and the
things that deal with how you start a
machine how i create the network i
create security i plug in load monster
and those types of things but this is
the issue well so we have two different
this is where i was originally going
where we have two different
types of apis we have how do i make the
systems work and how do i drive the
systems and then there are the apis for
things that are not the systems but
things that your application might use
like a simple db like an rds like go
through the list of of what i would call
up level things that amazon and frankly
ultimately i think other things offer uh
as as apis and so in my view you have
the application that might be consuming
an api and then you have the things
driving the machines right and i think
most of the probability is not in the
api because elastic cache is non-cache
rds is
basically my sequel and other databases
the elastic map videos is hadoop so most
of the services are actually services
that are not uh specific to amazon or to
any cloud
but if i write my stuff for
for
um
elastic
if i write my stuff for any of the
amazon services it's not like i just
literally point it over to yeah what i
said is that it's a narrow case in my
future sure out of the if you're just
looking at all this workshop yeah yeah
but if you look at the workload that is
running on most of the clouds
most of them don't use those provided
apis most of them
the problem is really dealing with the
network security load balancer image and
all those type of things
that's really where the probability i
would say 90 even though the probability
problem exists
now if you could abstract that and i'll
describe how to abstract that
then you minimize the problem and and
when i'm saying abstract it's basically
saying that if you have tens of
applications
if you could put the change or the
things that are specific to amazon in
one place then you minimize the change
if it's all scattered around the 10
application then it's a big problem so
just like being able to take all those
10 applications say when you work with
amazon work with amazon api we work with
openstack with openstack api but there's
gonna be one place which is gonna have
that details and knowledge
then that therefore by definition is
tenth
of the scope that it was otherwise so
just by doing that we can minimize the
airport now if it's a one after part if
it's a switch
taking that plug in and just changing it
in one place to another one that's not
shuttered so it's a big deal even if i
rip it and replace it i don't i i think
you're over simplifying i mean there are
ways to create portability and interop
but you know it's just not exactly that
simple i'll give you a very clear
example you build your application on
amazon web services use chef or puppet
to basically you know uh do all your
automation you're using the classic
networking model there's one network
interface on every vm and chef and
puppet use an algorithm to determine
what their ip is the ipa of the server
so you can use my ip yes so they use
that to basically bind applications and
configure applications when the
configuration management system runs you
take that app and you and you move it
over to rackspace public lab which has
two network interfaces per vm
now which one gets my ip is it the front
end network which you can attach public
ips to that behaves like amazon or is it
the back end network you get
non-deterministic behavior you go to a
vmware cloud you can have arbitrary
numbers of nics attached to a vm when
you spin it up so you can do a certain
amount of abstraction of apis but that's
not as important as getting similar
semantic and architectural behavior when
you're actually calling the apis right
because all apis do is initiate a
behavior
yeah and i would say that putting the
amazon api on top of it doesn't solve
that problem that's right uh it's going
to be the same problem and all i'm
saying is that don't hide that there is
a difference in that behavior right and
when you do the switch especially if
it's awesome
if the problem that you're targeting for
example right now is a one-off switch
it's a very small problem because you're
basically going to change the api when
you move to openstack into the openstack
api and that's fine and if it's
centralized in one place it's not such a
big effort if you're doing it
continuously if it's still if it's one
place it's not such a big effort that's
what i'm trying to say
so to this effect i mean there was there
was a lead-in that i think
it's a little bit of a religion but it's
important to how we think about this
whole ecosystem and that
it's close to what uh ngati has said and
those of you who follow community
heard of the work that's been done in
oslo db hawaiian release how many nodes
i'm talking about
okay so there was actually a fairly
sizable battle that uh mirantis guys led
to actually get database code you know
centralized in one place so that there
is a central way you can handle certain
things and it wouldn't be spread all
over the place and that's an
architectural thing that you have to
have so your code is maintainable so
that you have scalability and for
upgrades it's you know it's a foundation
to get the upgrades going so why is it
that we felt that um
this is an important initiative that we
wanted to spare at because nobody else
was doing it because without that you
can't have
your trunk uh be you know a powerful
enough um
you know version of openstack and why
are we doing that because there is a
whole bunch of customers that we're
talking with
uh and we have a lot of smart engineers
and by the way i might preface this i
forgot to say this and it's you know got
to give credit words do the reason we
are actually in openstack as a company
is because the first project we ever got
was the one that randy gave us internet
right so randy is kind of you know
uh as a father figure afraid of my own
worst enemy
i don't know it's the compliment
i love competing
well i don't think we're competing i
think there's enough for all of us oh
yeah but we're still competing
yes
we do this with bill too right and we
help them to build a competing product
so it's just the way you work you know
it works right and as a result we can
have a viable conversation about how to
make both our products work better
together absolutely on your own plenty
of room there you go so um
the reason we're so adamant about doing
this is because we have a lot of
engineers who come from a commercial
company background and what that means i
mean a lot of engineers in the room you
look at somebody else's code and you go
that's not done well i do it better and
then you put the smart guys there and
they actually do a great job and then
you go to a customers and they say who
embraced it yet how many people
contributing and what is this thing oh
it's working great that's wonderful i
don't want it
because it's not part of trunk and by
the way i don't even want to talk to you
unless it's part of trump and if you
can't do it just you know give me some
smart engineers i'll engineer it myself
or something like that and there is
not just your technology savvy customers
but we're finding that you know the
enterprise customers are starting to say
that too
so that um
for
and you know for
more people it's actually more important
that they're not buying a specific
solution to a specific problem but are
standardizing on something and they're
trying not to see it splitting up
so where i agree that there'll be plenty
of use cases where companies can create
a spot solution for that use case and do
a very good job on the survival business
model
ultimately for openstack to succeed it
needs to be agnostic and very very good
and quite frankly that's what we're
trying to do i know that's what red hat
is trying to do uh these guys have a
platform agenda we don't so we can
collaborate with them and compete with
them as well and you know they even
invested in us as
dell for the same reason because dell
has a platform agenda and we don't and
we can help each other but ultimately if
we can
force the standardization make openstack
better spend time in the community and
we are you know from being nowhere a
year ago we are
number four today in the community uh
for havana core number two for um uh in
in incubated projects and number one on
stack forge in general so it kind of
shows that we're committed to alex so
so assuming that um uh assuming that
you're correct how how does this get
solved so this is what you've said well
you've said that there are problems
because you can't get things into trunk
and that they're all of these issues
so the question is okay if we all agree
that that's the problem what is the
solution to the problem i think we you
know the the people active in the
community need to do a much stronger job
blinding around the technical committee
and driving a lot more architecture and
people with um
influence like randy and you know the
piston guys and the nebula guys and the
mirantis guys need to agree with that
the kick spaces guys for sure
um
we all need to agree that
the architecture of what the product is
you know there needs to be a centralized
architectural team that will agree and i
must say that when you talk to the
people in the community in the in the
technical
group it's called meritocracy based so
uh it's actually easy to get them to
agree on things if you frame it right
and i think we need to actually spend a
lot more time doing that
um and yeah that's that's that's your
answer
now we have a question yes yeah is that
going to matter if everybody gets
together and makes decisions like that
and you know gets on the same page if
red hat doesn't you know they control
you know most of the bills at this point
um if
they don't like something it gets very
they may not get blocked but then they
get blocked review for instance and
things go very slowly
we haven't seen any of that from
red hat guys yes they do control it but
like i said it's all meritocracy page so
we work with you know i mean with every
every core project and we've never seen
an issue that they don't like it for
whatever reason as long as you have good
merits of why you want to do it
and you're gonna talk about it before
and uh sell your ideas you know ask
community does it you have no problem
getting anything in
another question yes
what about security
what about security is that correct yeah
the question is how is generalized it's
a very general question yes it is it's a
it's a general question it's hard to
answer um the
nutshell is that it has a long way to go
and i'm being nice
and there are some serious
problems with the security and system
people like eric who's on my team you
know are working on they worked on that
what was that security guidebook was
that what was this
you did the security openstack security
yeah so there's some best practices
involving about how to deploy securely
there's a long way to go
um i did security full-time for seven
years
and then i got a little bit jaded with
the whole thing and the reality is is
that whether people like it or not
security always follows business value
so it's important but it's a second of
secondary importance so i think as we
get more and more openstack appointments
done the pressure will increase on
increasing the security and you already
see some of that with like red hat doing
things like baking in sc linux support
to their distribution so you'll see more
and more of that but it's gonna it's
always gonna lag a little bit so expect
a few years before it's like really rock
solid
and i wanted to comment to your question
i think that the the risk of having
dominant player in general is is always
a risk in those projects i mean it was
right space before and
now it's read out there was
some people think that ibm will be doing
it next and so the risk exists but i
think that the structure and the
diversity of players in the community is
such that
i think the community can still deal
with that and we have people like brandy
that would let this rackspace do very
very big
so so i think there is some self-balance
in the community to at least
you know something
definitely wrong is going that would be
enough voices that will raise their
voice and deal with that so i think that
it's a relatively lower risk when the
community is big enough that's that's my
compromise right and just a quick add to
this uh that i think so long as
customers are being adamant that they
want innovation come from the trunk and
whenever you come with a good solution
they'll tell you it's great but we don't
want it it will force us all to be on
the same page now how long will this
continue remains to be seen
but so far we've seen that being the
case
yes
so there's two main points related to
what you're talking about and what is
heat it's very important as it's
becoming kind of a way for doing this
sort of high level abstraction in the
unified manner but the other coming from
the other direction is the concept of
nailing down what open structure is
and there's i notice
discussions ongoing with the foundation
board of what openstack is going to be
and how each of the individual
distributions are going to have to line
up to consider openstack i'd love to
hear more about what your opinions are
in regards to how that plays into your
aws volume
it's
it's a very complex
situation i mean if you go to the board
right now and you ask people because
openstack does that code or the apis
you'll actually get very different
answers depending on whether it's one of
the technologists and software
developers or whether it's one of the
business people if you talk to a lot of
business people they tend to say it's
the apis and they don't care what's
behind that api
and if you talk to the software folks
it's typically you know they're all
about the software and they don't really
care about the apis believe it or not
you know i haven't had any pushback from
the ptl's about putting in google
compute engine apis or aws api updates
they just simply don't care they care
about the code and so it's a it's a
complex you know which one is it i don't
know i'm tempted to say it's both but
then you're kind of in the same place we
are now which is that it's both and you
haven't really resolved anything right
um and you know depending on which one
you pick whether it's apis or code
certain things become
very obvious like if it's apis then why
can't seph be part of openstack if it's
got the swift and s3 apis why not why
don't we just let it in right but if
it's software then you know it's a very
different thing right like why is it
that
something like swift or maybe keystone
or
uh salomometer can be a fully
opinionated stack that's not pluggable
at all or hardly at all
and is that opinion right
versus something like nova quantum and
cinder which are highly pluggable
systems they're almost at their own
leaky abstractions that can support a
number of different sort of solutions
underneath them you know what is that
what does that mean when we do that i
mean why are why is some software
allowed to do that and other projects
aren't it just it's a it's a very
complicated issue and in terms of how it
affects the aws apis i don't think it
does i think the right thing is to make
sure that there are good strong
low-level apis for each of the projects
and then we can put whatever bridges on
top of that that we need so you know i'm
not a big fan of cdmi the the open
standard object storage interface but uh
some people might want that if they want
to stick it on swift hey power to you i
don't really care we just need to make
sure it's done the way it makes sense
for the project
so i want to touch on your question
about heat and the two concepts but
before that i just want to compliment
what alex was saying i'm from video
spaces and from clarifying we also have
smart engineers just to put the plug
here
but anyway coming back to your question
there are two uh i think concept one of
them is the api capability but we didn't
discuss the templating model which is
the dsl model
and
i'm going to speak about it on behalf of
myself i'm not sure that i represent
anyone here in the room but
the question is really how the future is
going to look about how many people are
actually going to interact with api
versus templates
and that's i think will drive where
cloud would go in general i think that
will affect
openstack
so in my view
most users
wouldn't want to go to api to support
for example mysql or the application i
would want to say and i'll explain even
why can you explain who a user is first
yes so for example the user would be the
id of an organization that wants to
deploy the user would be developers that
is deploying an application
those users will basically want to say
here's my application i want it highly
available i want it you know scalable
with those criterias and those metrics
you know if it reaches this sla and this
sla
increasing incidents remove an instance
and and they would want to describe not
just the api but also the behavior of
the application
and just deploy it and they would also
want to replicate the
those definitions between one project to
another between one customer to another
even globally and that's kind of like i
think how the cloud stack is gonna be
consumed over time we're not there yet
but i think that's
and i see more people using cloud in
that way then
interacting with api directly and the
people that will be interacting with api
is mostly the ones that would be
actually implementing the orchestrators
of the which is a relatively small group
of users that will actually interact
with that with that
with
and those would be the bunch that will
actually speak at that level so if you
think about it in that way you also
understand my view of probability
is that we need that definition to be
more standardized and more open
and the api in my view is uh anecdotal
that they have
that it's specifically available because
if we make a good if we do a good job on
heat for example and defining that dsl
and making the definition and there is
also a work in tosca around that the
definition of what is a behavior how you
define a stack how you define an
application in a more common way
then
then you have one place in which you
need to make that template talk to the
right api and you minimize the scope of
that quite quite substantially so in my
view heat is
heat and the things that will be around
it would be the thing that will drive a
lot of that direction and maybe that's
where
openstack should be going
i agree but if i were to look at the
future
i think there is there is a formal
definition of what openstack is that the
foundation puts out and then
i think what we are bidding openstack
will become
and our best and my personal bet is that
openstack will become a full complete
stack from kind of soup to nuts you know
you did the soup part being the bottom
and will kind of go up
and we're seeing this already
that um
you know the openstack started as
core infrastructure bits and pieces of
storage and compute now we're talking
orchestration and we're talking about
control planes for hadoop and savannah
had their their their uh incubation
meeting and we're hoping that it will
become part of openstack right but it's
very far from you know uh compute and
storage it's already enabling
applications so moving up the stack and
the conversations we're having with
murano and cloudify is along the lines
and this is a core openstack
conversation so ultimately what's going
to happen is
uh it's about enabling users and users
in application to be able to use cloud
natively and the most efficiently and
the reason people are going to open
stack is because openstack is highly
configurable it can be optimized uh to
the specific application use case right
and uh
amazon is more generic than that right
so if you want to do that
you know as it becomes layer after layer
native you will use the native things
and move up the stat and it will be its
own fully functional step that will be
present in every enterprise every
service provider everything so it's it's
phenomenal right but it will grow from
bottom up
more and more up in the application
space that's our best
i
this will be i'm sure
a little provocative but i don't know if
i 100 agree that that's kind of the end
state
i think that's a state
in what ends up being more of a longer
term thing i think what we're going to
see is enterprises
adopt
i think we'll see them adopt a lot of
openstack and i think what they're going
to find is until they learn that
running things on a cloudy environment
is not the same thing as deploying a
copy of vsphere and throwing some
classic three-tier apps on it
that
they're not happy with the results and i
think that
most enterprises believe that cloud is
you deploy a copy of openstack or you
would deploy a copy of i don't care
cloud stack it doesn't matter you deploy
these things and magically you're going
to get this super incredible roi you can
have all this flexibility that you just
in no way could ever have and it's going
to it's going to be rainbows and
unicorns and i just don't think that's
going to be what happens i think they're
going to i think there'll be some
successes but i think there won't be the
roi that is expected i think until the
applications are adjusted to
better deal with cloudy infrastructure
you're not going to see that and i think
that there are swaths of i.t people that
are going to end up deploying openstack
and you're going to have a whole lot of
developers still writing that you know
i've got my web tier my app tier my
database and
you know it should just work what's the
problem i've been designing applications
like this for 15 years and
what do you mean i need to do something
different no this is the way i've been
doing it and until that changes i think
we're going to end up in a really bad
spot for a few years at least until word
gets out
the developers need to change the way
they do things too i don't think we're
there yet but i'm i'm predicting that
that's coming and when it does
they're going to be some interesting
phenomenon occurring
i'm going to agree and disagree i'm
awesome
the reality is right now is that there
are people who get that there are
enterprises and get that they're leaning
forward they you know devops is a real
hot button people are trying to get
their heads around it and i've been
shocked at how many of these financial
services companies i've gone into over
the past week while i've been here that
are already on amazon or using amazon in
some capacity so there are definitely
leaders who have figured it out the
thing that i'm going to agree with is
that i think that you get a tendency for
people to kind of want a cheaper v block
they sort of like you know in their head
you know cloud computing is virtual
machines on demand right and cloud
computing is not virtual machines on
demand it's not block storage on demand
it's not networking on man it's a new
model for it that the internet scale
guys have shown us openstack is a great
tool for getting there but like i said
before you could use openstack to build
a you could put it on fiber channel sand
brocade's in the mix now and they're
adding fiber channel drivers and all
that good stuff so you know you have
lots of options with openstack you can
build a classic you know vmware vsphere
based approach so i think that their
expectations aren't mismatched in that
you could do that with openstack but i
think what's happened that people don't
really realize is that openstack while
being very flexible actually has an
affinity for one approach and that
affinity looks more like amazon than it
does for vmware vsphere and i'll give
you an example if you want to use esx
and i've told vmware this like so many
times they totally just don't get it if
you want to use esx you've got this
problem where you can't run the nova
compute controller co-resident on esx
because you can't load code on an esx or
an esxi hypervisor because it's not you
know a traditional operating system like
you would have with kvm or xen so now
you wind up taking the nova compute
controller and you take it off and if
you want to control your esx nodes
directly without using vsphere you have
to run one instance of every nova
compute controller for every single node
in your system oh and then you need to
make it ha and then you need to monitor
it i mean so you just need more vmware
what's the problem
so then your next step is you do vsphere
on top of vsx and then you have no
compute controller managing the vsphere
cluster and it's just a cluster bleep
and so you know the the way that
openstack has been designed to date you
know it's not doesn't have very good
affinity for fiber channel scenes you
can make it do that but it's unnatural
right so and i think that that's kind of
where i agree with you again which is
that
you know
people's expectations are mismatched a
lot of time in the enterprise they think
that it's virtual machines on demand
they think they can download some open
source software and just basically spin
it up and then they've got you know
something between aws and vmware that
just works that's cloud that's cloud and
that and then you've got the sort of
like whole devops kind of like
application architecture change that is
um i don't see any way for the average
enterprise developer to get there except
using pass because you know they're just
not going to become sophisticated
building scale out applications and i
teach you up not actually
so i think most of you said with me by
the way yes so mostly
so i think you said two things
that i'm not sure that i would be uh
along with them to make sure they tried
real quick one is that application needs
to change to actually run on the cloud
not to run
but to run well without food then to
take photos
yes that's good okay that's a good
version so we might be
more agreeing than another ring
and the second uh
the second point that i think you make
is
that the the actual
guides on infrastructure with the
infrastructure itself is a moving target
and it's actually
still going to be there over the next or
the course of the next coming years and
i actually tend to agree with that and
the question is what do we do then
why do we do that and i i actually say
this is accept it as a reality the
infrastructure is not going to be stable
there is no button that is fast forward
on maturity and that's not going to
happen and the next coming years is
going to be
continuously changing technology on the
infrastructure embrace it
how do you embrace it the couple from it
for example no don't try to latch the
application too tight into the
infrastructure in that case you can have
two things that are going to be in the
collision course and they're never going
to match
each other and therefore you know you're
never going to be successful so by
decoupling it you let the train of the
infrastructure to evolve while the
application can latch on new versions
etc that that's true also for for purely
openstack with the different releases
that breaks
one another
uh so
so to your point i think that this is
the reality and the in the reality
the answer for that don't wait for it to
be stable embrace it as
a non-stable environment and the point
about the application if you really look
at the application or the service that
is most popular in the cloud today you
know what it is
i'm dying i'm
my signal there we go okay my sequel was
written where
like 20 years ago was it written for
cloud no was it reading to actually run
on the cloud no still it's the most
popular
so the thing that i'm trying to kind of
take and that was actually a lesson for
me because when i looked at that i said
when i looked when i was online without
yes i said
what the hell do you actually need to
shut down to upgrade
and the reality is that most people
embrace that and i said no maybe i'm
wrong and yes i was wrong
there is more pragmatic way in how you
could embrace cloud and the roi of cloud
then looking at the
from a
topical kind of point of view where you
look at the full value and say if you
don't raise the full value then you're
probably not a cloud and yes there are a
lot of great areas in that you could
actually get
seven degrees of automation and
automation for some people especially
those that are using mysql is to get and
spawn a new version of my sequel in a
few minutes even if there is a downtown
it's a weird problem
and if you could
uh automate the entire deployment that
failed from that that's a huge value yes
it's not highly available continuously
and so forth and so forth so if you take
more pragmatic approach to that
then you have better chance that you
could success succeed in your cloud
because there is no way you could change
all your application at one day and all
of a sudden they will become cloud-ready
and you don't want to wait for that to
happen as well
so
if i'm not sure if we agree or don't
disagree with that
it's interesting so i agree that
overnight i'm not aware of any
enterprise it can automatically change
the way all of their applications work
at the same time
you have to start somewhere and
if your starting point is
running mysql up on amazon
maybe that's a starting point it's
certainly not a point i would start at
in fact that's probably one of the last
things that i would that i would look to
do
certainly something that people can do
but i think it may indicate more of a
lot of misguided uh
people just trying to quickly solve a
problem which is more the startup
mentality of you just need to put it
together so it works versus putting it
together so that it's architected well
so it can scale out well so they can
deal with failure so that you can
upgrade without downtime so you can do
all of these other things
architecting and writing your
application to do that is something you
have to do
but i agree there's no enterprise that
can do it overnight
we're working on doing that right now at
horn music we are in the process of uh
green fielding and literally
moving entirely away from our classic
i.t architecture
but it's a many many years process
and
at the same time
you cannot
many applications
it is purely with a rewrite in fact i
would say 99.9 of all the applications
we will either reinvent or rewrite or
port by rewriting it's not something
that you can just go oh well you just
move this over here you move that and
put your web server here and you're
finished
there there's a
high degree of knowledge you have to
have of all of these we're all called
cloudy design patterns to be able to do
this
so
that's why i think it's a long ways off
before people will will really be able
to take advantage of this
alex i listen to this discussion and i
i'm concerned that we are taking a angle
which is uh mostly a technical aim and
you know when i
think of cloud
i don't think it's technology in fact um
if there's a parallel attitude well
it's it's
a law of economics right and so i think
the parallel that we should probably
look at is the moore's law
moore's law is essentially a law of
economics that describes the way people
are able to innovate
in like semiconductor space and so it
kind of gives you a innovation curve and
those companies that are able to
innovate faster and change faster than
the curve become intel's because their
whole business model would be one
generation ahead or more as well and
those who can't they're no longer with
us fairchilds conduct remember those
guys
and those who are on the curve are
actually still around so cloud computing
is essentially
a law that says that your constable your
efficiency your agility will actually
change you know will increase year to
year to certain percentage and there
will be some enterprises who will figure
this out and they will change
some will be ahead of the curve and
they'll grow some will be behind the
curve and they will disappear and others
will take their spot
but um
it's it's it's it's an economic claw
that will happen and i think the drivers
were having this done and warner music
is a great example of that you do that
because you have to change your
organization and
for the new applications that are
stateless and scalable you do it right
away in the amazon model or openstack
model for the others you make advantage
in devops and in development and testing
environments and through that you learn
to do it and that knowledge becomes
something that others piggyback off of
on the next generation of your
enterprise application and we see it
left and right and you know
the the ability of people to learn by
just taking what they have in
development and just playing the new
cloud has tremendous
human knowledge that then can
change the enterprise i think that's the
bigger driver than even the technology
um
yes but
it's i think it's i think it's a little
bit misleading to characterize cloud
computing as an economic model right
that's like characterizing you know uh
power you know utility power as being
about you know metered billion of your
power no there's a whole bunch of
technology that make sure that when you
plug into that light socket you get some
electricity and it's non-trivial
technology right it's extremely
non-trivial right in some cases things
like nuclear reactors right i mean these
are things that are very uh highly
technical and that allow for that
business model to exist so you can't
really decouple so
that's great technology you can't yeah
but you can't you can't it's a you can't
call cloud computing an economic model
that's just not fair you could say that
there is an aspect of cloud computing
that's an economic model that's critical
to understanding how to get competitive
advantage and stay relevant and i think
that's fine you just can't you know
hand hand-wave the technology and say
it's not about technology because
there's very critical technology aspects
to it that are part of what allows us to
get to that sort of business value that
you're you're highlighting but i'm not
disputing this
i'm not disputing this at all and when i
say it's akin to
moore's law there's a lot of very very
complex technology to get to from 28
nanometers to 21 nanometers and
it's
probably more complex than the things
we're talking about in the uh
cloud computing space but yet the law
says that we as a human race are able to
change that technology with a certain
speed and adopt this technology with a
certain speed so i'm not refuting
technology at all i'm just saying that
embracing this technology has to it has
to be happening by by us at the certain
speed that's the hello castro so i think
we're saying the same thing okay yes i
wanted to
kind of go back to your to your point
there and how do we actually what's the
right approach to actually improve the
application into the cloud and how is
that related to openstack so so we have
this meeting with bank of america this
week and and back to market for example
have 7000 applications the question that
came out that that
meeting was
how are you successful where a lot of
other people in the street
are still waiting around and you are
able to move faster
and that comes back to i think both the
economical model and the technical
aspect
what's the worst case scenario the worst
case scenario is that you build a cloud
like most people and i call it the
infrastructure
as a service first approach
they feel it they have a very fleshy
kind of environment with a lot of flashy
lights but then they go to the
application guys and they're saying well
but that's that's not what we want
and then they start and they're doing
second generation club third generation
club until they figure it out that's the
worst casino okay the other worst-case
scenario is that you're waiting for all
the applications to be ready and that as
you mentioned even in your case would be
a lot of years airflow
the best scenario is that you get
whatever you have the first thing that
you do just enjoy you know get it there
first of all what you'll find in that
process is that one you don't
necessarily need
to rewrite all of them because some of
them will die
but actually majority of them will die
naturally so it doesn't even worth the
effort to rewrite them
the new one will replace them but
wouldn't be in a rewrite it would be
just new application that will come
along
but you do that after you bring the
cloud not before that so so the dramatic
approach in that case is that if you
want to maximize your ri of the
investment
get as fast as possible all the
assets that you have into that new
investment because the worst case
scenario is running those two parallel
environment and the longer you have
those two pilot environment the worst
case in terms of cost and operational
cost and knowledge and transition all
those sort of things that's the case so
that's kind of the
the pragmatic approach i think amazon is
has shown us in many ways that they've
been doing i mean they've been
taking very very problematic approach
with the things that they've been doing
and they've been even breaking their
dogma
in certain cases and i'm sure they will
come also with private cloud soon after
they get the caa deal
uh
when they see a need for that and i
think that's the main lesson is that you
need to take a much more dramatic
approach to clouds if you really want to
be successful because the reality is
going to be the infrastructure is not
going to be stable an application can be
written to cloud in monday so i should
take my as400 system with cobalt code on
it and throw it in the cloud
so
people are considering it believe it or
not some people use drugs
are you saying you've never used it can
i get you on right you can't get me on
record on that
so no ways of 400 and no mainframe
sure yeah
so i'll put that outside and that would
require all my access databases and
excel spreadsheets i should put those on
the cloud right away they could be on
the cloud by the way some questions on
the audience yes question um
i've many times in my careers i've been
doing work in pc land like i had a long
career in identity management in ldap
and um the old mainframe guys were like
were looking at me saying that's a lot
like what we do in mainframe and then
when we got into virtualization they're
like wow that's a lot what we're doing
like we do in mainframe
and i was wondering and these apis seem
to have i don't have any experience with
an s390 now as these series myself i'm
wondering if you guys have heard or had
experience with
cloud cloud-like aspects within the
mainframe land and then larger questions
like orchestration in
the mainframe and managing workloads in
mainframe that we might be able to learn
from and when we look at heat when we
look at different aspects of what we're
building in openstack to get a little
the benefit of hindsight so the question
is are we going back to the mainframe
yes we are but how well and maybe we can
anticipate it this time instead of
having a mainframe guys say we already
did that no no we're going to go head
first right back to it
i don't i don't think we are i mean i've
seen i've seen this argument before
and and you know
i wish i had my my diagram for this that
i use you know kind of like here's
mainframe computing error here's your
enterprise computing error here's cloud
computing era you know if you look
across that there's there's stark
differences right i mean we're not our
proprietary big box hardware anymore
we're on a bunch of distributed
commodity hardware boxes right the
software architecture is distributed
we're highly dependent on the network
for communication system you know uh the
high availability happens in software
not so much in hardware anymore you
could just keep going on and on but
there are aspects that are similar but
that's just because you know there's
only so many tools in the it toolbox we
can pretend like you know it's infinite
but it really isn't right i mean there's
so many ways you do networking so many
ways you do storage you got spinning
discs you got flash you know and so you
just revisit a lot of the tools in the
toolbox as it evolves because that there
was a good idea virtualization on
mainframes was a good idea so i gave
vmware some some ideas and so they ran
with it but it's different each time
it's not a revisit it's just a
re-information i think the answer we're
searching for is that and then i'll let
you ask your question i think the answer
we're searching for is originally when
we had mainframes the hardware was
really really really really expensive
and it was hard to get a hold of and so
you were constrained by that and the
size of the hardware frankly because it
was huge you're certainly not going to
put a mainframe under your desk it's a
scale-up pattern right yes well it's
scale-up but it's also back to the whole
economics discussion it was damn
expensive to get a mainframe as all
scale-up solutions are yes and so we saw
we saw the mid minis and then we saw pcs
but it was even in the in the x86 era
originally it was still really expensive
to have
to have servers when we were building
the mysqls and the db2s and the oracles
and such when they were first coming out
all of the hardware for that stuff was
still really expensive so really what
you still had were scarce resources they
were less scarce but they were still
scarce
now following moore's law even further
and further when we talk about
distributed systems it's because we no
longer have a scarcity of resources
we're seeing an abundance of resources
and so because we have that abundance we
can take advantage of different
properties based on the abundance and
that's really where i see the
differences coming and that's why we'll
be able to treat and behave differently
is because there's an abundance right
more and more cores more storage more
memory um and so it can be more wasteful
we we will we will be more wasteful just
like we are with electricity by the way
if we go right back to the paradigm a
dozen people have written about um
but we're going to use it in different
ways because of that and we'll find new
uses that we would have never thought of
or found had it still been such a scarce
resource and you had a question sir well
i was just going to say i've actually
done automation on the s390s using
opsware
the lpars are not terrifically different
from the idea behind an lse in terms of
your partitioning and resource so it's a
docker
true
it's totally feasible but the reason why
people buy mainframes even in today's
day is because of those scarcity
resources it's in a data center the two
scarce resources are power and cooling
and
s390 in some cases can actually be a
better option than going on buying cheap
boxes in terms of the overall cost
because you lead a cost up front but the
long term costs could be a savings
especially for high io kind of workloads
right sure but i see a lot of people
using those just as vm houses
yeah i think that the fundamental
difference in my view that
cloud assumes uh that drives a lot of
the cost also is that it can happen and
it's just statistical whether it's a
high
high-end machines or low-end machines
and actually there's been a
an interesting research i think for the
first time that people did on storage
devices and one thing that came out of
that is that the failure statistic was
very almost the same between the
high-end disk and the largest lower-end
disk which
kind of proved that feather are
statistical the statistics happens all
over the place and therefore you need to
design for further versus avoid failure
from happening and the method was really
built from the concept that you could
avoid failures by having a hardened
hardware and very high-end hardware with
built-in redundancy between the algebra
itself but we all see in mainframe fails
and memphis do fail
and that's the fundamental difference
that also drive completely different
algorithms in terms of the way you're
doing orchestrations and some of those
things i would agree though that you
know we as an industry are not doing a
good job and i think that will still be
the reality of learning from past
experiences because we move into a new
world and immediately saying well
whatever was in the old world doesn't
worth anything and we're just trying to
uh and repeating errors of previous
mistakes i think that's the reality
those who are building the new world
usually are not the same guys that build
the old walls and the knowledge transfer
is not there
but that's the reality and i think we'll
probably do some mistakes that people
have found out 20 years ago yeah there
was this this guy who wrote an operating
system called c
that just
finished writing an operating system
called go
and the the
problems that he solved in go
are like yeah if i had been on the
mainframe doing centralized identity
you know 35 years ago i would have
written that into the initial takes at
sun's identity management services and
it would have just been the solution
that everybody used because it was right
um
i was
wondering
my poem is more towards the things that
are
now emerging from openstack especially
things like heat
and what we can learn from the past as
we craft together because tosca seemed
to me like something that i didn't want
to go near
um yeah so so first of all i think that
there are a couple of things about hosta
that i'll touch on but they're a good
thing about those kind of things about
dusk i wouldn't especially if you talk
about learning from past experience i
wouldn't rule out tesco completely
because there is one thing very good
about oscar is that there is a solid
definition of dependencies and a very
fine grain level what is an application
star what is the dependency between
component in the stacks and how you
describe them so there's a lot of things
that we can learn from tosca and
actually embrace them in openstack
rather than ruling that completely
because some errors looks very complex
that to human being
the way we are so i think
uh specifically on that of that on a the
world that you brought heat and tosca
i think that it would be the right thing
to actually build the next version of it
uh taking ideas from tosca and building
it in the right way within openstack in
general i think that the process of
driving the next the next version of the
future version of
of openstack is by looking at the
experience of what others have been
doing amazon for example and and doing
it
pretty much the same or better because
probably they figure out a certain way
that is working already so why not
learning from that example and implement
that and i think to read these points we
shouldn't look at
amazon or google as a competition we
actually should look at it as a
reference that we should not just
interoperate but actually embrace a good
thing not just
obviously not the bad things but at
least the good thing so we should recode
it in early
wow
yeah you know um
i always look at the sort of stack that
people think of as an inverted pyramid
with infrastructure at the bottom and
platform than apps and when i think
about it that way i think about reducing
variability at the infrastructure layer
right i mean automation works when
systems are homogeneous that's why
google has 10 hardware configurations
across 2 million servers right but then
as you start to go up the stack
variability actually starts to be
important because the way you're going
to solve a problem for net is different
from erlang is different from java is
different from a message-based
architecture versus a database focused
architecture i mean and there's valid
reasons to solve all those problems
using very different tooling and so for
me i look at something like heat and i
have a very simplistic view of heat i
see heat as being an application
installer right because say you've got
cloud foundry or prenda or some other
past solution
get it on your cloud how are you going
to get it on your cloud you you can't
they don't have an installer but he
could be a great lingua franca for how
you install an app now once you install
a prendent uninstall cloud foundry they
have different mechanisms for how they
drive the infrastructure as they should
because they might have different
requirements depending on the problem
they're trying to solve and so i don't
think we have to normalize that platform
layer at all i think we need to allow
people solve kind of the the
infrastructure management layer the
platform and app layers in their own in
their own way but we do need tools like
heat like without all the tosca baggage
to just do the simple bootstrap mean of
putting an app on right because or a
stack on i always think of heat as more
like a stack installer right and if you
look at how they're using it in the
openstack infrastructure team they use
heat to basically install open stack on
bare metal and that's that's valid right
i mean that's what it does it basically
bootstraps other people's code and then
that code takes over and runs i mean
that's how i look at heat
okay
question i don't know if anyone's ever
used ge radio but genius radio actually
presents an interface very similar to
something that we created called
operations orchestration in terms of the
idea of orchestrating process flows both
work fairly well if you want to look you
want to see how a functional process
orchestration framework works both of
those demonstrated fairly well i could
see heat plugging in there gnu radio
yeah it's used for
radio stuff for the cam radio software
radio especially so people will define
lots of software defined radio process
logic
but what you see is a good way for
visualizing large complex systems in
small blocks and they're interconnected
so
sure so there's a there's a
there's a it's basically like a flow
based programming or something like that
where
i'm trying to think of when i saw
recently no flow
which
which does flow styled
patterns where you have different flows
and you do transformations and such
against these i think it's used for uh
for doing things like etl and data
transformation it's the same idea what
you're describing where you have these
different blocks that do some some
different type of operation and you're
wiring them together into a flow
the comment that i have is that i think
we i hear a lot of discussions when we
talk about the frustration that people
bring a lot of the automation tools that
they have an arbitration tool that they
have an existing data center and say why
not use that
and i think there is a fundamental
difference between a lot of those tools
to the one that we expect in the clouds
and i think if we touch on devops one
fundamental difference is that if you
look at what a lot of those arbitration
tools is that they usually live in an
operational world island
and for example if i develop i don't
have access to that even
only the operational guards will have it
and there is a fundamental difference to
write a tool that will be friendly both
for developers and for the operation and
that's what we're seeing you know for
example again it's not necessarily the
right choice but the chef and and
obscure popular in both camps in the
world because they're more api friendly
they're written in ruby in a way that at
least developers can feel a little bit
more comfortable with that they're not
as good
to that problem as as much as i think
they should but still they're better
than a lot of those existing
orchestration tools another thing that
is important again with coming back to
heath is to look again what amazon did
so amazon had cloud formation
and they had the past there which is the
uh beanstalk but recently i think it was
february or march this year they they
bought ops for i'm not sure if all the
jobs work uh so offswork was kind of the
third now you would ask why they they
had cloud formation like hitting
so why did they added that middle layer
what was missing there what was the
point that they were trying to solve and
really at the end if you really look at
all the trends that happens at least on
top of the stack is that we have two
main forces one of them is control and
the other one is productivity or ease of
use
and we're trying to kind of write find
the right balance between the control
and ease of use if you're going to
extreme like in bin stuff during
appearance we looked at a lot of control
if we're going through extreme to the
control it becomes too complex well it
depends on the use case though right i
mean some things want more control and
some want uh you know more kind of
things being baked so it's yeah but the
ideal scenario is that you want to have
i would say both because it would sound
unreal
uh
but you would want the trade-off not to
be too extreme and i think today if you
look at the cloud formation and if you
look at the beanstalk the trade of this
clear extreme because in many cases i
want
i want the control and the ease of use
but not necessarily the ease of use that
passed
say the regular positive rocket kind of
powers would provide you so if you would
give me a way to draw my stack and even
plug into shaft or plug into whatever
definition that will give me control
over with which we have it's going to
run and and so forth and so forth
then why do you use that i i don't think
there's one size fits all i don't think
so at all but but i think that the two
extreme that exists
created a void in the middle oh
absolutely and that's what what that's
what i think ops work and
the question is how big that void in the
middle
is it small or is it very big i think
it's very big and i think that that's
what brought amazon to to actually
put something like that in the middle
which is not the pure pass but it's not
also the cloud formation of the world
and it's actually
something different that gives users the
control but with high degree of ease his
abuse
that this is very little to add i mean
we're very
we're very far from the amazon api
discussion where
you know we're talking about
you know the future of uh cloud really
not even openstack anymore right and uh
what's interesting is
that uh we're kind of doing exactly what
i said we're doing we're away from the
actual infrastructure now right we're
talking about how to make
applications and users actually use this
kind of stuff and i think that's where
innovation is moving right now and
that's the dialogues and we're having
this every day
in in our back rooms because
it has been about how do you make how do
you make infrastructure bits and bytes
work
and now that we're actually installing
this and customers are starting to use
them there is there are all kinds of
perceptions out there so there are
people who are trying to find management
usage models for openstack clouds in the
in the scale out world and that doesn't
exist right so everybody is building
their own solution and we're trying to
see you know what's better
and what exists now not very good and
then there is the other camp which is
the traditional people that have all the
management infrastructure with bmcs and
tools and all that and how can we fit
into that
and uh you know should openstack even go
there right and so
i think what what nazi and randy started
to talk about is how do you actually
tackle this problem i think it's it's
it's it's green field right now but
that's where
at some point there's only so much
savings you can ring out of
infrastructure and cloud
versus the value you can add by
providing different services and
capabilities to the business right so i
like to think of cloud as being all
about adding new value i i don't i don't
i think virtualization is about reducing
your cost of ownership i mean you know
the businesses by the way
i'm sure that you do the businesses i've
been talking to this week they're
looking at they're trying to create
flexibility
and speed inside the business the way i
think about this is like if you look at
a typical enterprise they have all these
smart people in there and then these
smart people are surrounded by this
giant ossified structure that makes it
impossible for them to get done
right i'm only a startup guy so all i've
ever done is get done so i can see
this from the outside
but those people have good intentions
and that's why they go to aws with that
permission to like get going on the
project they're trying to do and so if
you want to allow those enterprises to
move faster to actually you know be able
to be innovators you have to empower the
individuals in departments to basically
get done without the ossification
of the business basically holding them
back and i look at that as the primary
value of cloud computing right and the
way that you can see this the seed of
this came out of amazon.com right before
amazon web services they got into
position where all their ops guys they
couldn't be trained on all the
amazon.com products
there are thousands of them how could
they train the apps guys so the ops guy
said okay we're going to step back we're
going to build a framework and the dev
guys basically are responsible for their
products in production the developers
are going to push buttons and push their
code out without anybody's help and
that's what they did they empowered all
the developers inside of amazon.com and
that was really the seed that germinated
for a while and turned into amazon web
services and that's that's the the true
power of cloud computing is to unlock
the value of people developing new
applications and driving new value into
the business
i agree i think
what i'm the point i'm making is that if
you look at most i.t orgs in enterprises
they don't think that way today
absolutely they think it's all about
saving costs i.t is a cost center how
can we cut costs can i deploy openstack
to cut costs can i double virtualize to
cut costs what can i do to make the cost
lower
not about the value of the agility that
if you operate on a cloud you can get if
you properly leverage it
so this is a great lead-in to the
problem that you know that i think we
ought to solve as openstack ecosystem
that's the conversation that nike and
i've been having offline and not just
you know just us
uh a typical use case that we see is we
have application people who would love
to see openstack and you know
orchestration and development everything
kind of available to them in their
application today
and to enable that they know they'll
need six months if they have the
infrastructure but to have the
infrastructure inside the
big enterprise they need to have the
infrastructure guys set this up and
they're scared they don't know how to do
it it will take up two years in the
traditional enterprise setting to
actually get this done so you say two
years plus six months so i guess in two
and a half years maybe we'll get them
surprises to start adopting so the
question is is there a way to shorten
the path is there value we can bring
to the application guides today in the
auspices of the enterprise that will
actually allow them to use it today and
uh whoever can unlock this problem you
know will be the first type view of this
crowd and you know we've seen this
happen
um with apple revolution right um
five years ago you go to a meeting and
most people will have dell machines and
ibm you know compatibles and there'll be
one strange dude with an apple machine
with a meeting today in the crowd like
this 80 is apple machines how does you
know and they're all working for large
enterprises so just one day overnight i
work a lot with cisco one day overnight
i noticed that every cisco engineer is
kind of carrying and marketing that
carrying the
apple thing so the question is how do
you guys do it because you have to be
supported by the i.t organization well
the idea organization kind of is not
supporting apple and cisco but what they
did is they kind of said well because
there is such a ground swell of demand
we'll just do a deal with apple stores
and everybody will do a self-service of
that thing and you can just do whatever
you want and boom you know suddenly
eighty percent of all people insist
before you actually use the apple now
try to sell it in the it organization
that still be talking
right so if we can figure out a way to
go directly to the users and sell them
the value these guys will jump well you
know yeah
how do you unlock it
that's aws
no you just described aws no
they're going to figure out the
infrastructure first and then the
application came in they created
a luxury that i think most
developers inside the enterprise all the
time are writing apps up on aws and then
going to the business user and going
here's what i wrote and they're going
wow this is great they start using it
and at some point i.t catches wind and
that's when all of a sudden problems
occur so i want to touch on that because
i think that's kind of in my view the
main thing that i see
as the obstacle of enterprises adopting
cloud should we wait for the
infrastructure to actually make up the
application cloud enabled or leveraged
cloud and i think there are various ways
and you mentioned that here's a way to
do an idea i think we'll figure out
figure that is part of that out
is that you don't necessarily need to
wait for the infrastructure to be in the
cloud
per se one option is to bypass the
entirety and go to amazon and they start
there before and don't wait for the
infrastructure and once the
infrastructure is there you can route
the application back into your quality
that's one of the ten percent of the
yeah exactly the other option is to say
what is what do i need to do to make my
cloud my application ready for the cloud
do i actually need to have a cloud to
make the application ready for the cloud
and
my answer is that you don't necessarily
need to wait for that infrastructure to
be cloud to make your application ready
because what you need to make it ready
is make it elastic
make it something that could be deployed
automatically and that the way you
configure it will be automatically
the way you
deal with all the failures now would be
automatically now that this really
requires the fundamental requirements
that
underline infrastructure as a cloud
obviously if you like the cloud it helps
but up to some degree i can even take a
pool of bearing on machines and
environment application in an elastic
way but within a predefined pool
so
my point is that you could definitely
run and clarify your applications in
parallel to the process that the idea
needs to take to take to take its
infrastructure to the cloud
whether it bypassing the entirety or
whether you clarify it and by decoupling
your application from the it in one way
or the other you can move in parallel
path only when you're moving pilot path
you could actually converge much faster
as i think alex was talking about that
will
i think there will be so
yeah so i would say that
at least in the street
most people don't think in those terms
most of them that's why they stopped
bank of america i think that was the
first time that i've seen someone who's
actually thinking about that because
they actually created a group which is
an open source group and they embraced
some ideas from the outside to actually
do that most of the organizations are
getting with this infrastructure first
because they think that
what will get the infrastructure and it
will be stable then we'll bring the
application but it will never be stable
in the next three years it's not going
to be stable
and then even within the organization
that's going to be the high performance
cloud and it's going to be the consumer
cloud and this and that's going to
evolve i think
twice uh even
by next year
and that's going to be the reality and
most people don't yet realize that and
they don't think about it
i think alex really wants to say
something yeah so i think i i agree with
the approach on cloudifying i think it's
the right it's the right approach to
parallelize those two but i think it
will not solve the problem dramatically
because it will still take two years for
the bank of americas and uh
morgan stanley especially build this
with you even if your application rate
you still have to hurry up and wait and
that means that the value proposition
for the application owners will not be
there and therefore they'll not be
the you know the power behind the will
to do it so there has to be a way to
create a
hybrid solution whatever that means i
have some ideas but you know i just
speak at this level of abstraction where
you can take your cloudify id and couple
it with other infrastructure solutions
which are generic that could be built
into something that the enterprise can
embrace today
and whoever figures out that thing will
be able to recognize this value and the
time it takes to qualify an application
which is probably a six month period and
not have to wait the two years and that
will create competition for the it guys
who will say hey you know these guys
figure this out we better you know go
over the program or else we'll be able
to work tomorrow
and
you know the speed of adoption will
actually increase and i i you know we
have some ideas of how to do this but if
somebody if somebody can figure it out
and kind of you know create use cases
for that i think will greatly greatly
speed up the adoption of this thing and
enterprise
questions
we're just better anyway questions
comments pontifications somebody else
got about five minutes
we can wrap early
well if they're no more questions then
thank you very much
you